YouTube is punishing one of its biggest
stars Logan Paul days after he posted
video of the body of a man who had
committed suicide in Japan we just find
a dead person in a suicide forest
hanging well YouTube said yesterday
Logan Paul's channels are being removed
from its Google preferred platform
YouTube is also cutting Paul from a
series and suspending his original
projects the suicide video was up for 24
hours it has been seen about 6 million
times before Paul removed it himself and
apologized
Logan Paulo is 22 is known for his high
energy videos he has more than 15
million YouTube subscribers and he is
YouTube's fifth highest-paid star
reportedly earning more than twelve
million dollars last year now YouTube
has not made any policy changes about
controversial or graphic video even
after Paul's post from Japan is he
Lipowski is a senior writer at Wired and
joins us at the table to discuss hey Z
hi so he's he made a lot of money for
YouTube he made a lot of money for
himself they've taken action but is it
enough well this has been YouTube's
policy right they have a three strikes
you're out policy so they don't want to
censor you immediately right off the bat
if you make one mistake but they do want
there to be some penalties so removing
him from this preferred ad program is
supposed to really hit him where it
hurts this is a program where they
bundle their top content creators and
they put them in front of premium
advertisers and they really guarantee
these creators some revenue so he's
going to take a hit to his bank account
but his channel is still up and he has
15 million followers he's going to
continue to make ad revenue and I guess
it's up to his followers so if they want
to tune in why is his channel still up
if they took these acts as I said they
have this three-strikes-you're-out
policy the internet all these tech
companies they want to be inherently
open censorship is something they take
extremely seriously and so they they say
that you know if you if you if we've
told you three times you're out but he's
he's made one mistake he's 22 and I
think they're giving him the benefit of
the doubt leaving his channel up but
imposing some repercussions they're also
removing him from some of his original
shows that would have made him a lot of
money as well as he should there be
policy changes because YouTube didn't
take down that offensive video low
Paul took down that offensive video some
people say it took so long even for
YouTube to act right well the thing is
that video very clearly violated
YouTube's existing policy so it's not so
much that they need a policy change it's
that they need a moderation change so
they have committed to hiring 10,000
more moderators in 2018 the question is
is that ever gonna be enough you know
they have 400 hours of video going up
every single minute so they're using a
combination of technology algorithms
that automatically flag violent content
and also human moderators but they run
the risk of missing certain videos and
then over reaching on the other end of
the spectrum I mean here's kind of the
the conundrum is that provocative
content is what draws people to YouTube
right and this YouTube profits off that
provocative content so they don't want
to shut down what is a revenue stream
right exactly that's the that's the
business model of the Internet Facebook
faces this problem Twitter faces this
problem their entire business model is
set up to to benefit by reality so the
more viral a video is going to go the
better it is for YouTube so I think that
you know when ever YouTube ends up
coming out to explain why this video
stayed up for so long that's gonna have
to be part of the conversation was the
decision made that this video was so
beneficial to your business that it was
able to stay up and you maybe made
excuses for it despite the fact that it
did very clearly violate the policies
Logan Paul didn't respond to our request
but he did take down the content and he
said in a tweet he's taking time to
reflect so what's next for him I think
he's going to return at some point we
can take an example from PewDiePie who
was another YouTube creator perhaps
their most their most successful one and
around this time last year he faced
similar repercussions because a lot of
his content it turned out contained
anti-semitic and racist content and so
he was removed from the preferred ad
program he was removed from some
original content he's still up and
running you can do it really well yes he
is is he
Lipowski thank you so much for joining
us this morning